how do you become a software engineer in
2022
[Music]
i get this question a lot from people
who watch my military videos and ask me
how did you go from being an infantryman
to a software engineer well i never
really transitioned i've been
programming computers since 1982 when my
dad brought home a trs 80 computer from
radio shack and i sat down in front of
the thing at eight years old and learned
how to program in logo but a lot has
changed since 1982 and a lot has changed
since 2005 when i first got my computer
science degree so how would you become a
programmer in 2022 well to start let's
go over what a software engineer is and
what they actually do a software
engineer designs applications and
systems for computers but really a
software engineer uses computers to
solve problems and add value to a
business think about it like this do you
buy a drill because you need a drill or
do you buy a drill because you need a
hole the fact is as a software engineer
the business didn't hire you to write
software the business hired you to
create solutions that will help their
business run more efficiently as a
software engineer you are the drill and
the company needs holes you'll very
rarely ever write software for its own
sake
most business software is designed to
solve specific problems so really the
definition of a software engineer is
someone who solves real world problems
with computers now there's basically two
ways of becoming a software engineer in
2022 self-taught and college now
software engineering is one of those
unique professions where you don't
actually have to go to college in order
to get a good paying entry level job
okay think about this let's say you're a
bartender and for 15 years you've
attended bar and you really want to get
a new job because you want more stable
hours so you decide to go to a
programming boot camp how valuable would
you be to a software company that makes
of sale systems for bars and restaurants
you have real world experience that can
be applied directly to the business
knowledge of how a program will actually
work man companies would kill for
someone like that take a look at the
companies in your area and look for what
skills they're actually looking for then
pick a boot camp that teaches those
particular skills if you live in san
francisco java and react might be more
popular if you live in
minnesota.net might be more popular but
definitely pick the set of languages and
tools or stack that is most popular in
your area which will increase your
chances of getting a job now you can
also try online learning this may be a
good option for people who want to
continue to work while they go to school
now if you go down that path you want an
organization that can teach you classes
as well as provide you with
certifications now cloud academy is
actually pretty good with this mainly
because they teach and they have
certifications so funny story i have a
bachelor's degree in computer science i
have a master's degree in engineering
management and i have an msc in cyber
security now this is a cloud academy
website i want to show you something
when i have applied for jobs at cyber
security companies
they don't care that i have a master's
in cyber security all they care about is
this thing down here this uh
cissp certification this thing is like
the golden ticket into cyber security so
when you're looking for an online
learning tool pick one that has an
option to give you certifications that
way that certification can get you past
those ai job resume screeners now cloud
academy has a number of certifications
but i want to show you this one up here
this is aws aws certifications or amazon
web services you get an amazon web
services certification you're going to
be set up for the next 20 years netflix
uses aws disney is aws general electric
siemens so many companies use aws this
technology is going to be around for a
long long time get acquainted with it
one more important thing about online
learning and that is you're not taking
on hundreds of thousands of dollars in
debt to learn something unlike the next
thing i'm going to talk about
college now college is a little bit
different when picking a college i
wouldn't necessarily worry about a name
brand school now don't fall into the
trap of wondering if rutgers has a
better computer science program than
florida state if you're not an ivy
league school it really doesn't matter
just pick a school and graduate from it
that's the most important thing now
college is going to teach you
programming but one of the problems with
college is that it's not always on the
leading edge of programming so when you
graduate from college you may not have
all the necessary skills you need in
order to work for a company also keep in
mind the college will teach you theory
behind programming but one of the things
you lose is time in college you're doing
the work the professor wants you to do i
can't tell you how many times i've
gotten resumes from recent graduates and
i'm looking at these resumes and these
guys know how to convert fahrenheit to
celsius in four different languages
that's that's great but what i really
need you to do is take data and put it
into a database through a form so the
best advice i can give you is you're
gonna have to do extra work do a couple
of side projects put them on your resume
put them on your github as a hiring
manager i want to see what you can do
it's important to analyze your own
strengths and weaknesses figure out what
you like and what you don't like it's
also extremely important to get an
internship this helps you narrow down
the kind of jobs industries and
languages that you like the last thing
that you want is to end up in a job or
industry that you hate so get as many
internships as you can because you're
not going to know what you like until
you've tried it a few times internships
also help me as the hiring manager
figure out whether you'll be able to get
along with the team the days of the loan
bertram gilfoyle programmer are over
nobody wants to work with jerks no
matter how smart they are and
internships help prove to me that you
could get along with your co-workers i
actually want to talk about your dream
job it's actually not impossible to get
your dream job straight out of college
or boot camp but the odds of you getting
that dream job improve significantly if
you enter the labor force with a lot of
side projects a lot of certifications
and a lot of internships the more
interesting things you have on your
resume the greater the chance that
you'll get that dream job you need to
work for it
and then once you get it the work
doesn't stop once you get that job you
have to keep learning the best way of
doing this is to become what's called a
t-shaped engineer t-shaped engineer has
a wide knowledge of a lot of things and
deep knowledge in a couple of core
components so where does that bring us
back to cloud academy continuous
learning cloud academy is a tool for
techies by techies that's going to help
you with this continuous learning as you
progress in your career and actually
right now they're doing a seven day free
trial so if you're interested in that
click on the link or in the description
or the pin comments below and that's how
you become a programmer in 2022 good
luck on your next interview
[Music]
you